[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con de france 24
hablaremos sobre los impactos de las
cuarentenas y confinamientos que han
traído la pandemia por ccoo y 19 nos
acompaña la doctora magda gamba
nutricionista máster en fisiología e
investigadora de la universidad de berna
en suiza gracias por estar con nosotros
siempre las 24 cuenta de las cuarentenas
y confinamientos por los que hemos
pasado durante esta pandemia han hecho
que vamos a adaptarnos a nuevos hábitos
de vida cuáles han sido los principales
impactos en la salud física y mental de
las personas con todos estos cambios que
hemos vivido en el último año y medio
buenos días y muchas gracias
efectivamente los confinamientos han
tenido un impacto en nuestros hábitos de
vida muchas personas por ejemplo han
pasado a alimentarse de una forma menos
saludable y se ha aumentado también el
sedentarismo o la falta de movimiento
esto conlleva entonces que muchas
personas también presenten una ganancia
de peso o un exceso de peso estos tres
factores que he mencionado son factores
de riesgo para presentar en el futuro
enfermedades del corazón
o cáncer en cuanto a la salud mental lo
que hemos visto es un aumento de casos
de personas con estrés o con ansiedad y
a medida que la pandemia se mantiene y
las normas cambian constantemente pues
vemos personas que sufren de cuadros de
depresión abuso de sustancias como
drogas y alcohol y también personas
aumento en el caso de personas que se
autolesionan o con tendencias suicidas
doctora pero cuéntenos cómo afrontar los
efectos psicológicos de la pandemia y
sobre todo los confinamientos puede ser
por ejemplo la imposibilidad de unirse
con familiares amigos cuáles son esas
claves para afrontar estos cambios bueno
lo principal lo primero es entender que
es normal que todos en algún punto nos
sintamos estresados preocupados
angustiados ante la situación de crisis
en que estamos viviendo y como tú lo
mencionas pues tratar de mantener al
máximo ese contacto con nuestros seres
queridos familiares y amigos es crucial
para poder comunicar cómo nos estamos
sintiendo también es importante evitar
informarnos en sobre la pandemia en
medios no oficiales como por ejemplo las
redes sociales y por último pedir ayuda
psicológica de urgencia si es que
sentimos sabemos que estas emociones no
se están desbordando en nuestra vida
diaria o alentar a otros que lo hagan
bueno además como ustedes ya no lo decía
es normal sentir ansiedad depresión por
todo lo que ha traído esta pandemia y
todos estos cambios pero como
normalizarlo y hablar de esto
públicamente con tranquilidad una
sociedad que a veces este tipo de
síntomas como algo tabú incluso como
algo de debilidad la salud mental es un
tema que todavía no se aborda de frente
en los países latinoamericanos y el
planeta entero
exactamente bueno en primer lugar en lo
que tenemos que hacer es entender que no
estamos en una situación de normalidad
por lo tanto no podemos esperar que
otros o incluso nosotros mismos nos
comportemos de una forma normal o nos
sintamos como siempre bien entonces
teniendo esto en cuenta lo primero que
podemos hacer las personas del común es
normalizar las conversaciones sobre
nuestras emociones o sobre nuestra salud
mental como lo hacemos pues ojalá todos
teniendo alguien una persona por lo
menos de confianza con quien podamos
hablar sobre cómo nos sentimos sobre
cómo nos afecta la situación actual pero
también aprender a hacer escuchas esto
significa darle ese servicio de apoyo a
la persona que necesita desahogarse sin
juzgar y cuando entendemos que lo que lo
que yo siento también lo puedes sentir
el otro empezamos a entender que estas
emociones son normales para todos bajo
las condiciones que vivimos y pues por
último entender que es inherente a la
condición del ser humano
ser vulnerables emocionalmente bueno
rápidamente autor algunos tips que lo
sirvan para cuidar la salud mental y
física ejercicio una alimentación que
nos recomienda buena alimentación
incluir 5 porciones de frutas y verduras
al día actividad física 20 minutos al
día si no se es posible o mínimo 150 a
la semana con vídeos online si no
podemos salir ir al gimnasio hidratarnos
al día todos los días
constantemente y por lo menos dormir
cerca de unas 7 horas cada noche de
forma rutinaria muchas gracias por sus
recomendaciones de la doctora magda
gamba nutricionista máster en fisiología
investigadora de la universidad de berna
en suiza en cinco minutos con de france
24 continúan ustedes con más entradas 24
punto com
[Música]